as the uk officially begins its covet 19
vaccine rollout we are inching closer to
the same in the united states thank you
for joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez the fda is
releasing some new data today giving us
a little bit more insight into just how
effective these vaccines are really
going to be
orco mana joining us now live from unlv
to break down what we know and also what
we don't know just yet
orco well denise and brian once the
covet 19 vaccine becomes available
the unlv school of medicine hopes to
help administer it to the people of las
vegas
that could be right around the corner
with the fda saying
pfizer's vaccine is effective and safe
and
but there are still some unanswered
questions
it's more effective perhaps than imagine
a stunning success that's how medical
experts are describing the covet 19
vaccine while pfizer's vaccine has been
shown to be 95 percent effective there
are still questions about how it'll
impact certain groups
we don't know anything about this
vaccine in children yet
we also don't know about this vaccine in
pregnant women
unlv school of medicine dean dr mark j
khan says there's a similar uncertainty
for those with terminal illnesses and
compromised immune systems
once a vaccine is widely available we're
going to get some data
as to the safety in those populations
but the data that is available is
promising the fda
releasing new numbers tuesday showing
encouraging success rates in minority
communities that's especially important
in nevada where latinos have been the
hardest hit by the virus
as a woman of color as well as a
healthcare professional
it was really nice to see that in the
demographics that they did really have
a lot of study participants that came
from diverse backgrounds
the vaccine also did well across age
groups not only did they have similar
responses
but in some cases actually had less of a
likelihood of experiencing side effects
from the vaccine if they were older
but there's still the big question of
how long the vaccine will remain
effective
whether it lasts one year three years
five years or 10 years we just don't
know
the fda will bring its data to a panel
of independent scientists
later this week who decide whether to
grant pfizer's vaccine
emergency use authorization if that
happens
vaccines could be administered as soon
as this weekend
or next week reporting live from unlv
tonight orgomana 8 news now